well I just March the most important
time make sure you mute your phones
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast characterization of each
for I see 31 candidate particles and
Composition presented by SAS MIT dish
MOOC an associate scientist at SGS
Canada and sanofi pasteur Ltd in Toronto
and also joining us marina
Kirk a dasa who is the head of
biophysics and Confirmation unit
biochemistry platform at analytical Rd
North America Sanofi Ltd I'm Suzy Valdez
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's events we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Beckman Coulter Beckman Coulter focuses
on innovation reliability and efficiency
it's led us to become the partner of
choice for clinical research and
industrial customers around the globe
thank you for your sponsorship before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located at
the lower left of your presentation
window and type your questions into the
box that appear on the screen we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of our presentation also
please notice that you are viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right or use
that Q&A button
and let us know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
click on the button in the bottom left
corner and follow the process for
obtaining your credits without
any further ado I'd like to introduce
our two awesome present hey presenters
Jasmine - MOOC and marina Kirk ADATA
welcome both of you thank you for the
introduction and hello everybody and
thank you for joining us here for the
for the webinar we're going to focus in
the today's webinar mainly on one of the
vaccine candidate which is h4 IC 31 TB
vaccine candidate and the
characterization to do the same this
involves the characterization of the
particles and also the composition of
the candidate vaccine if we go here in
the today's outline so we will see here
some of the basic things that we would
like to emphasize on in terms of the
particles size and the particle
characterization of H 4 IC 31 which is a
candidate vaccine and IC 31 which is the
adjuvant used in this we do the phase
analysis light scattering and electrical
sensing zone these are the two
techniques we use for the particle size
distribution analysis further to that
the pulse which is a phase analysis a
light scattering can also estimate the
surface charge and zeta potential which
we will go into that details the next
thing would be to characterize its
individual compositions which h4 + IC 31
has as an IC 31 at U 1 it comes with
with the two different constituents klk
peptide and OD n 1 a raw material so we
will use Raman spectroscopy to
investigate and identify the
constituents the next thing would be h 4
antigen which is a protein that's that's
the main part of this candidate vaccine
and we use several spectroscopic
techniques to actually identify the
structural changes associated with this
as a effect of adjuvant ation and then
finally we will conclude today's talk
for any more information containing
concerning about the entire presentation
we already worked on the manuscript and
this is
already under obligation it's not
published yet so once that is out and
published then we will update this
information with lab rules and you can
have access to that for more information
so let's go further and then focus on
the size distribution the particle size
and and the surface charge so we will do
the characterization of the particles
Before we jump into that let's let's
have a look here so the TB vaccine
candidate which is h4 I 331 it has two
different constituents one is h4 which
is a fusion protein of two different
proteins which is AG 85 B which is this
protein here and then TV 10.4 which is a
dis protein here so as you can see from
the structural images here both proteins
have predominantly alpha helical content
and then in Ag 85 B you can also see
some beta sheets presence in the magenta
color which you can clearly see there so
H whole is the fusion protein of these
two the other thing which is IC 31 this
is a immunostimulant adjuvant so this is
a synthetic ed g1 it constitutes my anti
microbial polypeptide which is a KL k
this is a leucine rich polypeptide that
this has a +4 net charge and then the
second constituent is TL r 9 ligand
which is oligonucleotide reffered as OD
n 1a this has a minus 26 charge so the
combination of these two is IC 31 a g1
so these are in the ratio the molar
ratio is 1s 225 where KL k is in excess
and that's where the the total surface
charge of the IC 31 ad g 1 becomes
positive so it's a cationic synthetic
adjuvant we are working on this
candidate vaccine in the collaboration
with ssi statin serum Institute and wall
neighbor with the sanofi pasteur so
phase analysis light scattering is is a
technique where I
we look at the scattered light from the
colloidal solution to give you an
example so we have a colloidal solution
in the first example here where you can
see the large particles these particles
they move through the solution as a
Brownian motion and the scattered light
is collected where actually we can have
a look at the intensity fluctuations if
the particles are big enough the
intensity fluctuations is quite it's
quite low as you can see here in the
other example if the particle sizes are
small in size the intensity fluctuation
is more due to their rapid movement
through the solution which we call as a
diffusion so this is a very basic basic
thing whenever we observe whenever we
want you actually look into the particle
sizes through the phase analysis or the
dynamic light scattering technique
the laser light goes through the sample
as it's shown here and then the
scattered light is analyzed to get
information in terms of the particle
sizes in case of phase analysis light
scattering as it name suggests we are
looking here the signal processing is
based on the slight changes in the
phases of the the phase shift of the
light so one of the way one of the light
which is the reference light that that
doesn't alter anything and the light
which actually goes through the
colloidal solution can see a slight
changes in the phase phase of the light
and based on that phase shift it
correlates this information to the to
the diffusion of the particles and
finally to the particle size so this is
the basic principle of the phase
analysis like scattering method further
at address once there is a charged
particle involved into this analysis
then there is an external potential
applied as you can see in this
particular figure through the optical
probe and then the electrode once the
external potential is applied these
particles move in a different velocity
so altered velocities that is called as
electro phoretic mobility here so this
is measured by the by this in
tremendous azita attract instrument here
and based on this electro phoretic
mobility one can estimate the zeta
potential which is actually the total
charge of the particle and this is
important in case of all the colloidal
solution analysis and their stability to
give you for our further idea here so
electrochemical double layer as as the
charge particle is suspended into the
bulk solution in this case it's a it's a
negative charge for instance so once
this is suspended into the bulk solution
the counter ion will surround that
charge and form a very strong stern
layer which is the adsorbed layer so
this is a very strong layer after that
there is a diffuse layer where these
actually counter ions or the similar
ions they can diffuse in and out of the
bulk solution and and form a layer
around these charged particles the
leader potential is the potential
difference that is measured across this
boundary the boundary of diffuse layer
and then the bulk solution and as I
explained in the previous slide once we
know the electro phoretic mobility term
here the viscosity of the solvent is
known the dielectric constant of the
solvent is known and then one can easily
estimate zeta potential value based on
small husky's equation so the particle
sizes of h4i c31 candidate vaccine and
IC 31 adjuvant alone is analyzed by
using this false technique as we can see
here the particle sizes are very similar
in both cases except the fact that with
h4 presence with the IC 31 the particle
size is slightly higher and it has a
narrow distribution as you can see here
in the blue curve but besides that they
are very similar to one another the next
thing which is important to know is the
zeta potential so zeta potential is also
measured using this technique and h4 SZ
31 and IC 31 they have differences there
are quite large differences in terms of
the zeta potential and the conductivity
so the conductivity is the sir
this conductivity of of the particle
that we are measuring along with the
zeta potential by the same technique so
since there is a huge difference in
sweida potential and also the
conductivity we can use this technique
to distinguish h4i c31 formulation from
the IC 31 adjuvant and the reason behind
that is IC 31 and h4 IC 31 they both
have IC 31 in large quantity h4
concentration is very low so it's gonna
be really a challenge to determine H for
IC 31 from IC 31 from by using any
biophysical acids so to overcome this
challenge the pulse technique works very
well to identify and distinguish between
these two different formulations and
give us information about the particle
sizes zeta potential and the
conductivity so after this there will be
another orthogonal technique which we
implemented here for the measurement
that's an electrical sensing zone and to
discuss that I will hand over to Marina
and then she will walk you through the
esv um good morning everyone thank you
for joining so I saw Smith said that I
will continue on the electrical sensing
zone method I think in the meantime you
may see the poll question to basically
look through and share your knowledge or
understanding about this method if you
familiar with it or came across it in
your studies so basically the four
question is asking about the advantages
of this method versus of the particle
sizing and so few multiple choices are
presented so if you could kindly go
through it there will be great so
basically it's a particle size particle
count colloidal stability where they
independent own color chart
shape and transparency and so I guess we
can
in the mean time move to the next slide
and I start talking about the method
Oh question I'll close no so basically
you can see here the illustration of the
instrument we have and more importantly
over Kuta principle which is used it is
a foundation for electrical sensing zone
method the and the method is very say
well it's close to one century it's
quite old and when it was designed and
was mainly used for count of the blood
cell however over time it evolved and we
found a good application for it for the
biological compound we have a manuscript
I think you will see it on our previous
on the following slide where we have
extensively used it for the biological
England a therapeutic product called BCG
which is used for non invasive bladder
cancer and you may find there more
details about the method and how it's
applied in this presentation we share
further the application of it to the hy
31 and I scheduled on suspension to
characterize the the product in the
process so the principle is that
particles are put through orifice
concurrent with electrical current and
they produce a charged engine pattern
that is proportional to the volume of
the particle which is transversing or
moving through the orifice so in a long
left corner you will see the schematic
diagrams so it's a vessel or a beaker in
which the aperture is suspended and I
think I can draw it for you
just like those meteors just a second so
this is what I'm referring to this is
the beaker and down the aperture is
right here in orange you can see so if
you'll notice there is a line here that
shows that there is a little on opening
there we call it orifice and that's the
the liquid is traveling through the
orifice once the electrical count ISM is
applied the Pulsar in Independence
originates from the displacement of
electrolyte caused by the particle and
so this technique is really great
working on the displaced of the particle
and counting its relation into particle
diameter that's how you can calculate
apart particle size the voltage across
the aperture cut basically creates this
sensing zone the voltage occur the
scaling of the small sites in the volume
is used to acquire such a size
distribution so basically this method
can allow you to first of all non-elect
a non optical method so you're really
here and do not depend on particle
transparency on its color or shape you
really count every particle which
introduces the impedance in a flow as an
event so this is your count and the
intensity of it it's related to the
volume so you can't move count and
particle size the volume is versus fine
so there are two advantages another
advantage is that within the you
probably noticed right here there is a
computer with a kind of lot of digital
stream going collected from the sample
so because the measurement is taken
several times during the experiment
you're really getting an average of the
signal there is a way to calculate error
between each instance and so if we're
error or standard deviation is high it
is within the experiment not between the
runs I mean it means that you have
homogeneous if error is high it means
you have heterogeneous solution so you
have the really distribution of the
particles and you perhaps even have
visible particles in your sample
however in case of ice 31 NH was resumed
and we observe homogeneous solution of
their standard deviation is very small
and that basically means that indeed
it's the particle size most likely
homogeneous even and and it's steady
during experiment as well so it doesn't
change during the time of the famine
this is why using this method you can
uniquely characterize your colloidal
stability during Spanish not every
method can do that so that's the
advantage of it so if we move from this
slide should be resolved so here is the
basically in our summary so on the right
hand side you see the graph which is
some process volumes vs. diameter so in
our measurements we found that I see 31
typically slightly smaller that's about
the 2.9 on average that's what we get we
get we're getting a range but this is
average then I H for I see 31 which is
three point one in a small table you see
here it's a summary of our development
study where we I think we used several
days to analyze collecting data and that
into together allows us to calculate
intermediate precision so from run to
run from analyst to analyst so this is
really the numbers that you see so in
terms of percent CD before derived
volume it's very small
we're not sharing here the particle
count but what we learned that particle
count is reproducible from lot a lot of
a theater I see 31 particle count is
like smaller when h4 abound towards 231
but nevertheless from Watson what is
quite steady and it's in a ballpark of a
million so we are also suggesting to our
colleagues that they can use particle
count as a process characterization
because that direct measure of
reproducible
for the formulation and for sample prep
every time so below I think on the slide
in a very small print you see that you
can look further in our manuscript it's
an computational structural and
biotechnology journal this work was also
presented that their stock meeting this
is about the BCG in the therapeutic
product and because this paper is
predominantly based on electrical
sensing zone you can look us for more
details about this method if you're
interested so from that I think a
conclusion for particle sizing and
charge is that two methods both paths
any SDI in agreement about the size of
adjuvant in vaccine and they in the
range of two point six to three point
five microns so also both methods
illustrate that the size of argument is
just slightly smaller than that of
vaccine however I think the major
highlight here is the pulse method the
one that has me just presented to you
because it can differentiate between
very clearly using the other potential
are very clearly differentiate between
IC 31 adjuvant in vaccine and for
process it's very important because if
you have a bulk of adjuvant and a bulk
of vaccine these suspensions very much
look like so visual inspection will no
help whereas the past method even from
the of the conductivity right away you
will see other difference a very subtle
and Lance dimensions are the potential
the difference is very clear it's almost
half decreased by half these are the
potential for vaccine so that prevents
mistake during the feeling as you know
there is a step where we prepare product
in bulk and then it has to be connected
to feeling line and so I think it's some
discussion and we heard it from
regulators that they want to see more
techniques that
can control each step of the
manufacturing process so this method is
not just characterization of the product
but you can also use it to control the
process so that's how we want to convey
the values that we observe for this
technique
another thing that probably not
mentioned here but we talked about in
the paper and hopefully once it's
published you will read it as well
and that the charge is related to the
dose of age for protein rhy incision
because charge is directly related to
the ratio between protein antigen and
adjuvant and in this case the charge is
positive and it's related to the one to
9 ratio of the protein and adjuvant and
apparently it's very important for those
two to get an efficacy response and that
was observed in a clinic oh it's
published now it's in clinical studies
phase one that they saw response and
also in animals in in the whole blood as
they published by brutal obstacle
so moving to the next slide were
introducing different technology now as
seismic mentioned I see 31 adjuvant is a
biological argument which is consisting
of the peptide klk peptide and odn one
oligonucleotide and those biological
products they constitute raw material
for us and so to in order to
characterize the raw materials we deploy
Raman spectroscopy so this light in in
brief introduces their principle of
Raman spectroscopy technique so this is
spectroscopic technique which is based
on inelastic
light scattering and with and is used to
observe more molecular vibrations and
other more frequency modes in the sample
so as you know the majority of scattered
light is governed under a rally law so
it's arouse gathering when the incident
light which is scattered from the air
molecule from the atom does not change
it
see what is in this case that is a
frequency shift on the stock shift is
recorded and this is our foundation to
judge about different bonds you can
relate to different bonds you can
identify them in the raw material and
also on overall you get the signature
profile which is unique to a particular
compound and you can use this signature
profile for comparisons and lots a lot
so on the lower panel here you see
Aramis the trustee for raw materials and
vaccine formulation so the panel which
is presented at the angle of the those
are actually real graphs real real
spectra collected for raw materials for
the media and once you have a profile
for the media spectrum for the media you
can compare it with the individual raw
materials and elucidate Peaks that are
present or remain present in the media
so that's another application to use and
this is just to illustrate how much more
you can do with a Raman spectroscopy or
Raman spectroscopy in general will
specifically portable instrument for the
study of raw material but the main goal
in this particular study that were
presenting here today is to characterize
the raw materials used it as an invasive
or for a lot of loss comparison and also
to monitor how stable these raw
materials are because to formulate you
always have to achieve certain size and
as we learn from electrical sensing zone
method also to achieve such a number of
particles after the mixing and so
obviously any degradation and any
alteration in raw materials can be
problematic so this is why it's good to
know the starting point have a
collection of good representative
spectra and use it as a reference for
the future future raw materials incoming
raw material Oh
right hand side you can see the top
panel you want to put key okay which
produces quite a lot of Peaks and on the
bottom panel you have Odeon one
oligonucleotide even just without the
deep analysis you can see that first of
all this is a tool to differentiate
between raw materials or Kok and Odeon
one you can distinguish the differences
therefore this can be used even to
prevent mistake during formulation
because assassination
Kayle Kayle is the predominant component
and so definitely you want you want to
have it correctly for formulation and
again they were counted white powders
they very much look alike so to have
spectroscopic definitive technique is is
a good way to go to play and to have
correct formulation so this slide shows
that you can actually zoom into the
peaks identify peak position and also
assign Peaks to the specific side chains
or bonds
and twist and so that can be compared
with literature data what is this in
known for the peptide and Olga
nucleotide and basically assign
accordingly therefore the the best way
are signed to calculate en 1 so on the
next slide I think the conclusion from
that that the Peaks identify first of
all close agreement with similar peptide
to the nucleotides published but also
these Peaks are fingerprints they can
identify raw materials that can be used
to qualifier potential impurities and
evidence but more importantly even at
the very first step when you formulate
your German you have a control not to
make mistakes and use proper compounds
to achieve desirable ratio so I think
with that switching back to saw Smith
and he will take on the h4 structure
Oshin and in the adjuvant form in
hyo-jung nothing thank you very much
Thank You marina for elaborating nicely
on here's the end introducing the Raman
spectroscopy the way we use it to
identify the raw materials and
characterize it further so as we have
seen that what these techniques can do
in terms of analyzing and characterizing
complex vaccine vaccine products here so
before I move on to the next session
what I would like to do here is push two
of the poll questions here based on what
marina and I discussed so far so that
just to have an opinion what audience is
thinking on this so as you can see on
your screen the question is what are the
different techniques that can be used to
identify the raw materials so we have a
couple of list of techniques there which
you think might be useful to identify
the raw materials involving the the
vaccine products and not the protein
itself so so just make sure that you're
answering questions keeping in mind the
raw material identification and
meanwhile once you're answering the
question the second question that would
also come on your screen so that would
ask you if the Raman spectroscopy can be
implemented to elicit a secondary
structure of the protein besides the raw
material identification which marina
just mentioned and once the policy is
closed so hopefully you will see the
answers on your screen what majority of
people think in terms of analysis of the
raw materials identification of the raw
materials and also if we can do the
analysis and characterization of the
protein secondary structure by using the
Raman spectroscopy so concerning the
second poll question I would go further
and then I'll keep explaining what we
can do here so now we have the results
already coming
than showing on the screen that the raw
material to identifies its Raman which
is actually true most of the time we use
Raman spectroscopy which is very easy
and very straightforward to identify
different raw materials besides that I
would also like to mention that FTIR is
also used in that particular sense
because FTR and Raman are quite
orthogonal techniques and they rely on
basic principle which is similar even
though they have a different selection
rule which I will explain if I go into
details of that and the other thing
which other industry industrial
applications or other people use is the
ICP inductively coupled plasma so that
is also useful technique to identify the
raw materials and traces element trace
middle into the product the second poll
result is also out as all of you said
yes and that's actually true the Raman
spectroscopy can also be used to elicit
it and get information on the secondary
structure of the protein which is not
actually very common practice so we
explored more into this area and then we
decided to continue and use the Raman
spectroscopy not only to identify the
raw materials but also use this
technique to to go further and annal
analyze the protein and characterize the
proteins structural changes with this
now the next section what I'm talking
here is the h4 antigen which is the
fusion protein which I described earlier
on and we use the different
spectroscopic techniques here to to
identify the structural changes because
as h4 the fusion protein binds to the IC
31 so inherently the matrix and the
environment of the protein is changing
so we anticipate that there has to be a
structural changes in order to
compensate this new environment which
fusion protein is seeing now these
structural changes are quite crucial so
it's very important to know what's
happening with the structures so that we
can identify them and we can track this
for for the future references whenever
we have this candidate vaccines in the
process another very important thing
here I would like to emphasize here h4
IC 31 is a very complex product that we
are working here h4 has
fusion proteins so all its components
are water-soluble I see 31 has two
different components klk which is a
peptide and Oh DN 1 a which is illegal
nucleotide these are water-soluble too
but once they are combined to make IC 31
they become de forma particles and these
are insoluble particles and they don't
change once H 4 is absorbed unto them H
4 is a very low in concentration so it
doesn't really change much of the IC 30
once particle characteristics as you've
seen from the particle sizes so that's
why we're dealing here with complex
substance complex product and then most
of the techniques which rely on soluble
assays we can't really apply those
techniques here and whenever we want to
get more information so the possibility
is to desorb this component so that we
will have a H 4 separated from IC 31 and
analyze them separately or manipulate
their environmental conditions in a
harsh way so that we can get extra we
can get information what we are looking
for but both of these techniques involve
the harsh manipulation and we're not
probing actually native conditions what
these samples are actually in so keeping
that in mind we are developing this set
of new techniques which we can actually
use and implement it in that direction
to probe the native state of this
candidate vaccine here so the next thing
what is what we're going to see here is
the Raman spectra of H for IC 31 IC 31
and the free edge full-form in the in
the top panel in the graph what you see
here is we have h 4 IC 31 tres recorded
and we have IC 31 trace recorded as you
can see in a different color the reason
behind that is we want to see what is
what happens with the edge for protein
in the adsorb form so that's why we
collected the true spectra by H for IC
31 in ads or phone and then we're going
to subtract IC 30 one's contribution to
that spectrum which you can see as a
brown trace here in this which is
already subtracted IC 31 so the brown
trace here in the lower panel tells you
only the changes which are coming from
adsorbed H 4
and the green trace actually tells you H
for which is a pure h4 without any I see
that even presence in that and as you
can see in the lower lower panel that
the spectral differences are quite
significant which we can actually rely
on this information and get more from
the from the proteins structural point
of view there are quite a variations in
terms of the the spectral features here
but I would like to focus your attention
to a tiny bit here in the green trace
which you can see here and then another
peak here which is again in the free
form of h4 that belongs to the alpha
helical content of the protein and that
actually disappears as its as it goes
into the adsorb form which we don't see
in the brown trace the next important
thing here which is quite predominant
and that I would say the presence of
this peak here which which gives us
information that the beta sheet content
is increased in the brown trace which is
that salt form so as protein goes from
the free form to the ads or pond we've
seen that alpha helical content
decreased and the beta sheet contained
actually increased so this is just the
secondary structural information and
then if you go on further you can also
estimate based on the other spectral
features which I'm not going into
details here but you can actually look
for the amino acid side chains and their
environment is changing as the protein
is going from going from the free form
to the adsorb form so this is quite
informative information if we can get
from from the Raman spectroscopy and
considering the the simplicity and the
ease of operation of the Raman
spectroscopy so this is quite
informative here so we observe this is
very important to note here we observe
that the beta sheet contained actually
increased in the edge 4 in that Zoar
form now obviously the next technique
would be to check this using the
circular dichroism spectrum so the
circular dichroism spectrum here we are
using as everyone of us are familiar
with the technique we are using search
polarized light and we are actually
checking here the absorption differences
from the light left handed and the right
handed light here and this gives us
quite solid information about the
proteins secondary structural
information in the far UV range which we
are monitoring here on the top panel
here the alpha helical content for the
free edge for form is 16% and the beta
sheet is 37% if you can remember from
the structural figure which I showed you
earlier on that we have predominantly
alpha helical content in both proteins
the the different constituents of the
fusion protein and we also had AG 85 be
having some beta sheet contents in the
magenta color which I showed you earlier
on so that actually tells us that we
have some beta sheet and alpha helical
content so we actually D convoluted this
spectrum using the yanks model to get
more information about the secondary
secondary structural information here
now quite peculiarly we can say that
because we saw the minima 208 and 222
that that tells us that the result for
helical content and then some beta sheet
if you if you d convolute the spectrum
further after adsorption what we see
here exclusively form h 4 but in the
adsorb form because we subtracted the
Icicle even contribution from that
instead of seeing the two minima
208 and 222 we see in this case now only
the broad minima at 218 which gives us
an idea that this has to have a beta
sheet content rather than alpha helical
content so deconvolution and analysis
further tells us that the beta sheet
contained is quite dramatically
increased here to 57% and alpha helical
content decreased from 16 to roughly 5
percent so again we are in the same line
so we are actually confirming the same
results what we actually found from the
Raman spectroscopy and this is in line
with the Raman spectroscopy results now
as I briefly mentioned that the Raman
spectroscopy is also orthogonal method
with the FTIR the only difference here
is the selection rule is different Raman
spectroscopy is based on change in the
polarization versus FTIR
based on changing dipole moment so this
selection rule is different so sometimes
what happens whatever signals you are
seeing in the in the raman we may not
see in FTIR and vice-versa because some
of the vibrational modes are Raman
active some of the vibrational more
Sarepta are active as we all know about
this therefore we decided to go further
and then also did FTIR analysis on that
the FTIR analysis what we have in our
laboratory is based on attenuated total
reflectance which is this is actually
ATR crystal based technique which is
shown here if you can see I'm just
trying to mark there to focus your
attention to there so this has an ATR
crystals where the the infrared beam
comes from one side of of the crystal
and then it propagates through the
crystals by doing several reflections
within the crystals and on top of on on
top of the crystal that's where you're
going to deposit or you going to put
your sample on here on the surface and
as the the light passes through the
multiple reflections through the crystal
the even isn't field will transfer and
travel through the sample and then this
information is is is extracted and it's
it's analyzed by the detector what we
are seeing here
so this is a very sensitive way of doing
the analysis using FTIR so we could
extract much more information which we
already saw from the Raman spectroscopy
and then this particular thing what we
are seeing here these are the ground
state spectrum recorded for 3 H 4 H 4 IC
31 together and IC 31 as a separate so
free H 4 is shown here in the green
spectrum in the in the in third and then
the red and the blue there H 4 IC 31 and
IC 31 and then we subtract the IC 31 to
extract information from the adsorb h 4
form and then we compare that with the
free edge 4 form and as you can see here
the blue and the red trace in the lower
in third they're quite similar so we are
actually probing here very marginal
differences because if you can recall it
my earlier discussion that h4
concentration is very less here i see 31
we use as marine also mentioned in
excess which is a nine-fold excess so we
are dealing here with very little
concentration of the protein so we're
seeing very small changes from the
spectrum that's why we had to use the
different spectroscopy to get that
information from the spectrum and even
though the different spectroscopy would
not tell you precisely how much
difference you're seeing therefore the
second derivative spectrum the
calculated one here it's a better way to
get actually more information from the
spectrum and that's what we did here so
we can put it at the second derivative
spectrum and as this is a secondary
radio spectrum the Peaks are upside down
here so whatever is downward it's
actually peak because we are looking to
secondary radio spectrum within this
spectrum as you can see that the dash
lines which which are drawn here for a
might 1 and a my two region they are
quite distinct if we compare the two
traces the 3 h4 from the green and then
the h4 which is absorbed from from the
h4 I see 31 the brown Turris so at those
dashed lines there are quite pronounced
differences already we are seeing that
coming from the Umayyad region so there
are already structural changes
associated with that but in context with
the previous of our findings that I
would like to focus your attention with
the similar findings the peak at this
here which is a 1689 peak and then
another peak at here which is a 1588
this tells us that the beta sheet
contained in this particular sample
increased which we didn't see in the
green trace in the free form so the beta
sheet contained quite dramatically
increased which is which we also have
the proof from the CD and Raman
spectroscopy so which is in line with
the previous findings besides these
there are some other changes also
happening so we have we have a random
coil changes here and then we also have
have a small peak here which is coming
from the turn so we can actually
distinguish what's happening with the
different secondary structural contains
and also what's happening with the amino
acid side chains which is this region
here so we can also estimate what's
happening in
in the amino acids actions as the
protein sees the transition from the
free form to the absorb form so these
tiny structural details and molecular
information can be easily extracted from
the complex material what we are
actually dealing with here which is a
candidate vaccine and we can correlate
this information to get more more of
spectral information besides the
particle information which we described
earlier on so this this gives a whole
set of set of tools where we can analyze
the analyze and characterize that the
particles and its composition the
individual constituents from the
spectroscopy and we can also probe the
structural changes what the what the
protein antigen is is is facing here so
again we are on the same track here the
beta sheet contained is increased as we
seen from the previous previous two
techniques so this is actually quite
quite good and we can confirm that this
is the changes which is occurring in
each four I see 31 candidate vaccine now
so far we are sure that okay this is the
changes alpha-helical contained is
lowering and the beta sheet content is
increased as as it absorbs onto the IC
31 so what might be causing this so this
is like another question that people
might ask okay the reason behind this
could be the possible reason because
this is not the only protein where we
are seeing the alpha to beta transition
switch there are other proteins for
instance our photosystem 2 that also
undergoes alpha to beta transition
switch under the bright illumination and
there are some other proteins - in the
literature where actually the transition
can happen between alpha to beta and
beta sheet to alpha helical content in
our case our protein is is longer than
26 amino acid residues so once the
protein which has a predominantly alpha
helices it absorbs and compactly back
onto the onto the adjuvant particle then
it experiences the dipole repulsion
within the Alpha helices and as a result
of that the alpha helices tend to
stretch on the surface of the particle
because they want to minimize these
repulsive forces and once it gets
stretched it converts to the more
favorable form
the beta-sheet and that's why we are
seeing here more of a beta sheet
formation rather than the alpha helices
which is which is which is energetically
more favorable to have it on a particles
particle surface and this is what we can
explain based on the information what we
gathered from from the spectroscopic
data so in order so finally to conclude
here the pulse which is the phase
analysis light scattering method is is a
very effective way to differentiate h4
IC 31 and IC 31 a g1 because they are
identically they are very identical
formulation since we are dealing with
high concentrations of IC 31 which is
nine folds in excess at leaf and then
this also gives us a little potential
information the winter potential also
gives us the charge information so if we
have a positive or a negative then we
can say that which particular component
is in excess because H four I think that
even as I explained it's it's a cationic
due to the higher charges of polypeptide
KL key and H 4 is a has a net negative
charge on its surface so we can actually
estimate which one is playing role here
based on the charge of the zeta
potential and the zeta potential also
gives us an idea about about the
stability of the sample because in other
simpler terms the zeta potential gives
us information about the repulsive
forces between the between the particles
so if we have a strong enough repulsive
forces the colloidal solution it's
stable if we do not have strong enough
repulsive forces the colloidal particles
will coagulate and then sediment so
which means the stability is compromised
in that situation
so we can extract that information from
pause and considering the complexity of
the the sample what we are dealing here
the second thing what we actually
demonstrated here is the beta sheet
secondary structural contain that
increased as a result of adjuvant ation
in case of fusion protein h4 so that is
also very very new information for us
and then we can use this information to
probe the future formulation process
changes
and a lot too large comparisons to to
see if everything is falling in place
because these changes even the
structural changes with the h4 can
actually play a role in immunomodulatory
response so these are quite important
parameters to actually verify and study
the the next thing what we showed here
is the spectroscopic techniques that can
be used in a non-invasive way to get
information about the structural content
of the antigen without desorption step
as other techniques can also get the
information but then they have to deal
with the desorption technique or they
had to manipulate their environmental
condition in a harsh way so to probe the
native conditions I think the set of
tools and the characterization package
we just demonstrated that that gives
some advantage to get more information
and track these in terms of the quality
of the vaccine development and also the
processes so overall this is this is
going to be a useful package that we
also want to implement for another
candidate vaccines within the industry
so hopefully we we provided enough
evidences and enough information to to
actually provide some information and
drive the work force towards words using
some of these techniques in a
non-invasive way to extract more
information in a complex material so
with that we would like to acknowledge a
few people here from analytical rnd
biochemistry sanofi pasteur Bruce Carr
peak is the director at biochemistry
platform and Sanofi parson of the
pasture for all his his support and his
guidance through the project West Cermak
Ellison kimochi pan dal hee they
actually did the C D and E SV
measurements so we would like to thank
those people also Wendy Chi who actually
helped us preparing the samples for the
Raman spectroscopy and from the
bioprocess rnd formulations at sanofi
pasteur Roger
and Emily shell for generously providing
us the samples and with that I would
like to thank all of you for being here
with us and listening to the talk so
thank all of you thank you very much
thank you sassman and marina for that
informative presentation we will now
start a live Q&A portion of the webinar
if you have questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's go ahead and get started
we've got several questions coming in
from our audience in considering methods
to characterize process versus methods
to characterize product are these the
same yeah well as as we were discussing
this the characterization process if I
understand the question correctly so
you're asking the difference between the
characterization process versus
characterizing the product right that's
correct okay so the characterization
process if there are changes in the
process that can be characterized in
differently so now we are trying to
implement these techniques in an inline
mode so whenever there is a process the
formulation process taking place within
the industrial setup so we can monitor
all of these changes in line by using
the different probes for the Ramanand
FTIR and also for the particle sizing
whereas for the characterizing product
so we can also implement the similar set
of tools and rigorously characterize
those in terms of the different
attributes which we presented in today's
webinar I think the other thing to add
perhaps would be when you characterize
the process you also look at different
aspects for example excipients residuals
residuals often constitute different
sets
methods can vary from master it can be
ramen as well we deployed in and Marvel
have publication on the cholesterol
basically our residual in the HSV viral
product you can even look up Rehema
Hitomi she's first over there so
basically it's somewhat very but trust
me it is right the main goal for the
process and changes for let's put it
that way for process validation is to
examine whether any changes up in the
upstream or downstream in the
purification constitute changes to the
product and therefore characterization
tools become their prominent in that
regard and they also in a part of all
electronic biological license
applications that we have for common
technical document if you if you
submitted for EMA in European agency so
bottom line is that they part of it to
for characterization tools you often
come if there is an investigation is
there is any significant change in the
processes happen to change sides you
change for example manufacturing
buildings that occurred it we're facing
one right now so a lot of tools that you
see here today is one of examples they
can be deployed for characterizing the
process from building to building or
side to side if you will in terms of in
depth for process as I said you may need
to look deeper I mean go into media and
check for excipient check for your
residuals have other type of tools
they're not necessarily cold product but
the more process related perhaps but
overall there is a merit be subtle
difference by and large you have more
similar techniques and different for
that
- awesome Thank You marina and tasmat we
have audience members from all over the
world today here's another important
question coming in what is the scope of
minimum sufficient
development that would be capable to
generate meaningful results so I think
that's a question about how you approach
new products for example something that
you don't know much about or just
challenged and so you probably go with
the methods you know well perhaps or if
you know something but potential
critical quality attributes of the
product you may come from that
perspective what is really important
what do we want to achieve so in our
perspective its confirmation that is
designed or is not present in such way
that it can elucidate energetic response
trigger immunogenic response whether
it's adjuvant has to be M in this case
the or9 agonist to trigger the innate
immunity first before you add adaptive
immunity starts to work so from that
perspective I would say that minimum
sufficient is I guess respects the
method to choose and the requirements
for the method for example impulse that
certainly presents today important is to
do dilutions and you may be well aware
of that dilutions you'd make for one
product not the same for another but to
get a reasonable conductivity and in
order to comply with Norfolk equation
you have to have certain values I think
it's not to surpass what 500
conductivity to to get meaningful
results so that's minimal sufficient for
perhaps if you want to go deeper than
you check a lot a lot of differences and
basically conclude how confident you are
to recommend this technique Adam you are
for example tool of choice and to take
it from a preclinical stage all the way
to phase 3 because there are such
techniques that you can and there are
some that happen in early stages we keep
them maybe until phase 2 and then
phase three we say that we have
sufficient information we know that they
work well but they not as inside
differences want them to be and we just
face them out and make a
characterization package much more aslim
and more economical if you will
cost-effective to go on to faithfully so
minimal sufficient I guess is to comply
with method requirements to be to have
certain concentration that basically are
appropriate for the technique of
dilutions in that matter or for example
for ramen we learned that we cannot form
any in this case we better work with
solids rather than liquid solid has to
be dry Thank You marina our next
question coming in from our audience
members is what is platform analytical
methods in your view it is a database of
possible outputs ready to answer
questions quickly or is it the beginning
of product specific method development
so I don't know maybe Sussman wants to
answer yeah well I would say maybe it's
more of a product specific method
development and then in terms of going
back to the previous question also and
maybe linking that to to this question
so the scope of method development and
also the product specific method
development I would just like to add
there is just keeping this one thing in
mind about about about any method
development that we are probing actually
in native or near native conditions to
avoid any results which are actually
discrepancies rather in a native
conditions because once we try to
analyze so the techniques would require
different ways of analysis and different
assay conditions and we might alter
significantly from actual native native
conditions so this might give us some
kind of results which are not exactly
related to what we are looking for so
it's it's it's critical just to keep
that one thing in mind and then try to
develop
or access methods which are actually
capable to use enough information that
is the question
I'm just looking at them I'm think I
think you have we have time for one last
question from our audience members
here's another one what is the charge of
each for well as far as we know of age
for its positively charged protein
that's why we use klk as negatively
charged to to basically absorb it for
for the because quelque is negatively
charged peptides as far as I know and so
for absorption that's important yeah
it's just the reverse I'm just
correcting so I for the I see 31 has a
leucine rich a polypeptide so which is a
positively charged predominantly and we
are using IC 31 way in excess and that's
why it's a positive so H force net
negative charge it has a net negative
charge and we deduce that from the amino
acid sequences what are the acidic
residues involved onto the surface or so
it's it's a negative charge
and that's why we can have a ionic
interaction between those yes and also
to mention that this is a really strong
binding so if you want to dissociate
it's it's possible but it's quite hard
that's why we kind of promoting here
that to analyze as is in the native
state as opposed to have a dissociated
state of the United States
yeah and a formulation occurs about 6.8
pH 6.8 and then brings bring it back to
77.7 7.78 that's the final look seen our
page judgment in the
thank you so much for today's
presentation and for your important
research I'd also like to take the time
to thank lab roots and to our sponsor
Beckman Coulter for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 2018 you
will receive an email from our roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thanks for joining us
and we hope to see you again soon okay
thank you